good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Margo Lauren I'm about to
revolutionize your farming life
introducing you're not open eyes
the not open eyes is the latest in
market our patented farming technology
that's gonna improve your life in every
way and you're not gonna see why until I
do it right now so as you can see that
not open eyes is the state-of-the-art
farming equipment that every modern
farmer needs in their daily existence
because otherwise you're just living in
the 19th century we want to move forward
to the 20th century hooray fireworks for
everybody
the not urbanize is also oh crap excuse
me we seem to be having some technical
God not man eyes is the latest in margul
our patented farming technology as you
can see it's got a a bank of thrusters
here that allow a tilling of the fields
to be faster and easier than ever before
have you ever had trouble rubber
rustling up all of your cattle in one
place well this is not what I wanted
holy hell that's worked better before I
swear this products good you're gonna
love the not urbanize I bet my dollars
on it make me look bad well [ __ ] I swear
this worked before why is it suddenly
not working now there we go the knot
urbanize is god damn it hey the nominees
is the best farming tool you're ever
gonna have in your entire life and
you're never gonna need another thing
after that as soon as I can coordinate
exactly where I need no that's wrong Wow
the patented thrusting action of the
knot of an eyes is definitely what's
gonna get you in the farming world as
you can plainly see the uses are endless
for the knot of an ax whoops that's not
what I meant to do I bet why is that
thing doing no no no I'll get you not a
benign but not abandoned threat not a
minimize the not even the not a man died
but not of an eyes
not open eyes comes with a patented
cannon for farming ray the non-urbanized
can also be used to remove those pesky
stones that you find in your house every
once in a while
hip-hop hep well this seems to be
problematic I'm gonna get ya the knot
urbanize will not be stopped
apparently the knot urbanize is being
stopped in case that wasn't good enough
the knot urbanize can be adjusted to
have explosives to remove those
particularly expected pad pesky stones
[ __ ] non-urbanized can also be modified
for your everyday uses such as blowing
up castles oh [ __ ]
remember kids don't try this at home not
urbanize has two convenient ball holders
in the front oh god damnit not urbanize
has two convenient ball holders in the
front I'm gonna blow you away I'm gonna
blow you way but not urbanize worth
every penny seventeen thousand payments
of $29.99 cents also included with every
purchase or free flamethrowers and also
everything that you need for your
everyday farming life well crap
I can still maneuver you ding-dong
I did it I mean the not open eyes did it
buy one today tired of those pesky harps
getting in your way not open eyes to the
rescue to the rescue I did it in two
seconds flat
thank you fall the time you're gonna say
with our new tractor farming equipment
it's farming equipment really is say
hello to the neighbors
holy [ __ ] what's happening here all my
purse you like that I can't [ __ ] god
damn it god damn and I did it holy crap
that took so many tries okay so if you
want to order you're not urbanizing they
improve your farming life and just call
1 888 no pen15 188 no pen15
remember our slogan is life's hard
shouldn't you be - thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see
in the next video